hi dina what are you doing
well the last time we talked we helped
katie at cat tube use web hooks to set
up a system for processing github issues
i'm worried the functions may not
complete before they time out
or there might be an error and the whole
thing will fail
i think we have just the thing to help
katie improve her web hook
[Music]
katie's web hook is currently set up to
create notifications
trigger an action and stream data into
bigquery
that's a lot for one webhook you're
right
her current system works but it's
fragile everything is
tangled together and running
synchronously this means we're not
returning a response to github until
all the functions have completed that's
risky business
given that each of these services are
constrained by timeouts
cloud run has a 15 minute timeout but
github
wants a valid response within 10 seconds
of its request
kde's request must be completed by the
shorter of these two timeouts
katie will probably be able to complete
all three functions in under 10 seconds
but i wouldn't want to rely on probably
luckily we can use pub sub to
asynchronously handle
the events from the github api
katie creates a new cloud run endpoint
to be the initial webhook target
this new endpoint will verify the
signature publish the message to pub sub
and quickly return a 200 okay status
message to github
thus allowing the rest of the work to be
processed asynchronously
but once you send the message to pub sub
uh how do you trigger those functions
well we need to create another service
and have
it subscribed to the pub sub topic this
way it'll be triggered whenever a
message is posted to the topic
for additional security when we create
the service we should allow
only authorized requests and set up pub
sub to send us
authorization tokens here we can look at
our reconfigured slack function
it's confirming that the data it
receives looks like a pub sub message
and then triggers the notification to
slack
thanks to our setup we don't have to
worry about authorization
or signature verification our
architecture
looks a little more complicated now but
we've solved our issue with the timeouts
and as an added bonus this kind of
decoupling
creates a system that is better able to
handle errors
uh what do you mean dana well by
creating separate services for our three
different functions
we ensure that if one service has an
error the other two
are not affected this is one of the
benefits of a
micro service architecture that's great
but what do we do about the errors in
the broken service
if the message is not successfully
delivered
pub sub will keep retrying until it
succeeds
once we have the service back online the
messages will be processed through our
healthy service
so before katie's web hook target worked
but it was synchronously triggering
three distinct functions
meaning it was at risk for timeouts and
for one error
in one function taking down the whole
service
that's right but now that katie has
rewritten her web hook to send
all events through pub sub she has a
more robust and
fault tolerant web hook target ready to
take on the world
thanks to pub sub and a microservice
architecture katie can rest assured that
her team
isn't missing any notifications or
losing any data